okay I told you last week that the top
donation to our IndieGoGo campaign which
will end on the day of this guy right
here's inauguration Donald Trump was 499
dollars from Joshua last week that was
surpassed by 25 hundred dollar donations
one from Sarah and one from a guy I will
call Nick number one those remain the
largest single donations other than the
thirty to thirty-five hundred dollar
single donation which was a matching
donation last week that's kind of its
own thing but a different Nick we will
call him Nick number two has made a
number of donations which together total
five hundred and eighty eight dollars
and now Nick number two also known as
nick reed is the new leader so with just
two days to go five hundred and eighty
eight dollars is the high water mark for
contributions from one person can
someone else do it we're getting to the
end of the road would be Trump Ian or
inauguration just 48 hours away even if
you can if you can't donate 588 but you
can donate five or eight or two dollars
we've had a hundred and sixty donations
roughly at ten dollars or less small
donations matter big league or Bigley
whichever you want I mean I'm flexible
I'm sort of agnostic on big league
versus Bigley please get the men in it
ends on @midnight we can't figure out if
it's midnight Eastern or midnight
pacific on Inauguration Day it doesn't
really matter though it ends on
Inauguration Day this is it david
pakman.com slash donate